we are here today because we are about
halfway through the summer would you say
the say it ain't so yeah july twenty six
Tuesday july twenty six it's like the
day after the 25th yeah continues going
forward these days yeah July's a weird
one where the days go in order um so I
don't know where we're coming up on
august there are a few big profile games
i guess in that month but we kind of
want to talk about what to play the rest
of the summer there's always a lull i
think a couple weeks ago Danny we had
talked about a games if you missed this
year that you should play that we're
probably gonna be talking about for game
to your consideration like I'd said like
XCOM to the witness play those if you
haven't yet we want to talk about what's
coming out the rest of the summer there
are a few I want to go chronologically
but first I just wanna get another way
because it's all anyone's talking about
is no man's sky yeah seems like if it
works out it's an ideal summer game
right cuz they can kill time you can
just you know theoretically you could
just be exploring for you know weeks and
weeks and weeks until sep tember you
know usually before we're done exploring
the real world in pokemon go you go back
into your living room turn off the
lights and just avoid the sunlight in no
man's sky yeah exactly that's but like
we talked about enough about no man's
sky on the lobby we covered it we you
know it's gone gold it's ready we don't
have code for review yet no knows one
will get it um so we'll just get that
out of the way yeah that's the big
profile one but I mean there are a few
more in August and then kind of going
into September which is still a little
bit of little September's pretty light
before the fall release schedule stars
October is just a UH tur [ __ ] show you
take in a good way number toppers not
summer no I know I'm saying like before
we get into the fall schedule I don't
know so first August second there's a
couple games there's AB sooo yeah what
do you guys think of that you are you
excited for that at all I look forward
to it tell me your abs like you absa
it's no it's just the enclosure of wild
ABS running around oh but I played it
recently at a like a III and it's you
know like underwater xp3 is an
underwater be underwater exposition
correct illogical and traala G exam
which if you passed you could be an
entrant all exist now I played it it's I
so it's very much like an not a
narrative maybe but it's this very
surreal estate kind of underwater just
exploring for the sake of exploring it
sounds like journey my
mm-hmm may I think that's the vein
they're going for flower I think the
lead designer or lead artist or
something yeah does yeah punch externa
people it's that kind of water color
scheme I guess almost the scheme they're
trying to scheme you into it no but uh
the last time I played it they kind of
revealed this like supernatural stuff
you go into this Blake with in a lake
under an air lake within the ocean
underneath it and you gonna this weird
alternate dimension I don't know it
controls pretty well like swimming is
you know historically pretty bad in
video games think they finally figured
it out like five years ago but up until
two thousand eleven man swimming was the
worst up until Rayman Origins swimming
was awful Rayman Origins just nailed it
you just tap a button number another
game that did that Mario it's gonna say
yeah nothing new they figured it out
like day one and then just continue to
screw it up with like majora's mask
which is why my favorite games but
swimming is bad and I oh yeah that the
water temple yeah anyway August second
that's ABS you we're also going to have
Batman the tell-tale series episode one
realm of shadows I don't know I'm not a
much of a Telltale Games fan I recognize
they're like recognize like the pedigree
that there that they have because
they're really good narratives I love
walking dead season one I started the
wolf among us I'm interested to see what
they're gonna do with Batman because
they're a lot of interesting stories to
tell I just said yesterday they're gonna
have multiplayer for the first time yeah
I'm not sure how that works I don't
either I didn't even like click into it
I don't believe this yeah I don't know
this isn't true this is not true
Telltale's got good writers and their
their stories are always kind of you
know like they are well written I think
the characters are well developed so I'm
interested to see their take on Bruce
Wayne um I just get bored with those
games yeah I don't know I can't if I'm
playing a game I'd rather watch a movie
like with those you know like not that
games can't tell a great story at all
but like this kind of game I just get
bored of the mechanics and doesn't
everything you're not reviewing it yeah
oh yeah I'm not reviewing that novel
style of game something like a phoenix
wright game coming out like i'm still
excited for that that narrative
experience because we don't really get
that a lot especially with Western games
where you're basically just enjoying the
story and it's not as much focused on
the gameplay it's just here's a cool
story read it
or let kind of listen to it yes and you
know those choices they say it's like
that gives you the illusion of choice
right but then there aren't that many
the endings gonna be the same in
telltale games right that's the thing
with what they're very few ranches Alvin
comes back yeah there are very few
endings or maybe there's two endings
what do you think you guys gonna take
the time with someone to play this I got
too many games to play I'm not a dig
Batman guy I think that's my hang up
here the Batman's the side I'm excited
about like I mean a lot of people never
able most people aside from like cynical
Peter Browns like Batman now it is so
your addy but no yeah tell shell most of
us are Marvel there's gonna be a
telltale marvel game as well I'm a
little bit more excited for that yeah
marvel ya see what see if they can
capitalize on this you know like you can
tell are like so many gamers that's what
I want telltale anime yeah just all in
of what prop is done anything like every
make up your own it re Goku give me
Naruto give me one punch man that's
soooo give me one punch man is that the
name of it one punch man that is the
name of the anime what's that about it's
about a guy I haven't seen much of it
it's about a guy who's pretty
expressionless who doesn't really care
about much but he can defeat anyone with
one punch sounds like I would read to it
I your podcast talking with you talking
about anime man it's maybe like we
should make one that just sounds like
Brad Pitt from a snatch uh-uh remember
when he panicked and they see they'll be
subtitles that do ? swim points you
don't know what he said it's become a
movie podcast all of a sudden yeah sorry
anyway so that those are both those are
both August second dad man and Abdul no
man's sky August ninth we already talked
about that we have talked about
extensively and then probably the other
big one for the month is Deus Ex mankind
divided which I am personally excited
for curious about because I loved human
Revolution man kind of it-- it looks
like it's going to be the same vein that
kind of like a you know System Shock
dishonored kind of vein of you can play
through areas like like it's a shooter
but it can be a stealth game it can be
this like narrative game refining a
little like tidbits in the environment
to kind of flesh out the world skyworth
has been covering it he seems pretty
positive about it so far um that's later
this month I don't know there's a lot of
criticisms as well to heart but it's not
going to be locking you into or it's not
gonna especially with the bosses i think
was one of the big problems with that
you punish these are like stealthily
yeah yeah that if you want to do
anything other than combat it's not
going to be that much fun when you get
to a boss yeah and hopefully they do
actually salt that this time I wonder if
Adam Jensen is the same voice actor yeah
tell me how you feel about that Pete I
just not a fan no magic Johnson it's
funny we transition from Madison voice
actor doesn't sound convincing you could
politely his intonation everything I
can't you could put like the cowl on him
and you just think it's he's Bruce Wayne
kinda but like a poor man's Bruce Wayne
I just raspy over the top like we been
drinking heroin or something who a
better Adam Jensen I don't know but the
game played clips that I saw from scotts
preview event thing the NPC's had more
convincing voices than the lead
character which is totally threw me off
I am very curious about the game at
large I just have to turn down the
voice-over volume or something yeah I
mixed I just read it all in Keanu Reeves
voice yeah perfect since good pro like
every video game that has subtitles in
my head I turn off the voices and I just
hear Keanu Reeves in my head that's
perfect because he's almost as monotone
as I don't um pretty monotone but take
take take there's a good story to read
post keep going give the government back
their jobs what movie that was um so
yeah this day sucks man kind of item
excited for it looks like yeah if same
thing with dishonor to if they cannot
punish you for going like the stealth
route which I liked which I i love
stealth games i want to do that i'd play
through both these games like twice
human Revolution and dishonored 1 i'm
hoping they can kind of remedy those
problems that i as well as a lot of
people had Justin you're kind of worried
about this one on August 30th world of
warcraft legions oh I'm I'm worried not
because of the game I'm worried because
of what it will do to my productivity to
your zest of my life mm-hm cuz like
every every time a new expansion comes
out as much as I say like I'm done I'm
done with Warcraft we did I don't need
to play this anymore but then the
expansion comes you're like well you
know I could play for another you know
hundred hours or so just like drop it in
you know just another hundred no bit
yeah they have closets the transmogrify
two point oh you can change your outfits
on the fly what's like real life is that
so your tummy closets is one of the name
of the what's going on with leading door
we talking like a hinge what kind of
closet area
closets to give you full access to your
wardrobe even any quest that you beat in
the past you can suddenly go back any of
the choices that you might have made for
equipment in the past you get both
choices this is he as someone who has a
passing interest in world of warcraft
and it was never never really never
really addicted to it at all I never
sent meant more than probably I don't
know 30 hours in it I know senator
legislate 30 yeah well like there's not
there oh honey I didn't orc hunter which
I understand is kind of a noob character
I know hunters are easy to level up and
it will scoff at me depending on how
long ago you did it if you spent 30
hours like you know three or four years
ago you're not going to have native you
probably didn't get a very big
experience if you spent 30 hours in the
last year you probably a level cap
probably yeah that's because I not not
really there was a joke oh I have no
idea they increased the leveling really
really trust me with this cuz I'm just
agreeing holes it's not funny everything
sale of Warcraft no it's not it's not
funny I can attest to that but what is
it like there's a lot of their story
draw I'm assuming like this there's
always a lot of these side quests that
yeah yeah there's another hero that you
get to play as the last year that we got
was death knight and now you're going to
get to play as a demon hunter which I
I'm interested in more I haven't tried
it on the public test realm but it seems
like an interesting new gimmick to throw
in there and of course a little bit more
story increased level cap all that gives
you more reason to grind away in the
game but I it's something that always
draws you in and we've seen on
subscriber numbers that it pulls you in
for a limited amount of time and then
the subscribers drop off again and
you're kind of left with that core
audience and people who have not stopped
playing warcraft since it came out which
is still you know more people then I
think any other paid MMO but is all down
a lot from its prime of over 10 million
over what 12 14 million back in the day
yeah I like I said I've never been like
huge into it but I don't know every time
this is the time to join oh my god a
hoarder Alliance Alliance really
Alliance all my friend from high school
used to like laugh at alliance it's
because they're wimps they don't
understand the lure of a real team I
made much like team valor and poking
go if you're not team valor and you
could have chosen a dumb team like
mystic or instinct but team valor the
Alliance these are just natural choices
I haven't played much Pokemon go but I
feel like if I do I'm gonna join
instinct just to troll everyone as I
like to tell people I'm a Hufflepuff and
I like to say that if I if I play
pokemon sun moon I'm gonna pick pop leo
is either one that no one likes yeah you
know trolling people by choosing
instinct that I think the the house
chooses you as the harry potter fans
might say throw on the head and see what
happens all right last one in august
same day as Legion August 30th this is a
game I'm assuming all three of us played
and many other people pretty seminal
game in the third person action shooter
survival horror scene res evil 4 is
coming to ps4 and xbox one that they all
come to xbox one ps4 pc yeah remastered
what do you guys you want to jump back
into this game I don't have time what do
you want in your time you want I have to
play new games that remasters this is a
new gonna remaster it's to the port it's
just a poor yes but I misspoke with the
remaster this is not gonna look any
better like 12 versions of this game
which I like to seem a lot but I'm cool
you can get a fence was not reasonable
for by the way no you can get a physical
case you can get a physical case with
this now on ps4 which I as someone who
likes resin evil a lot and we talk about
a dead air podcast I'm excited to play I
have six five and four or six and five
now and ps4 I don't know I'm I'll
probably play it again someone told me
that at the beginning in the ganado
village you know how like you have to
keep fighting in the beginning until the
bell rings and they all go back to the
church I consider myself a huge fan of
series but someone told me if you shoot
the bell yourself you can just end it
right there do you guys happen to know
if that's true or not on there maybe the
twitch chat can tell me if it's on like
youtube or something I don't know
because that blows my mind I've never in
like the ten times I planted a puzzle
solving that's that's what a boss fight
and Miller solved three the against the
end where you can shoot him in his
wheelchair like at the very last second
of the cutscene leading up to the boss
fight and totally negate the whole fight
yeah or you can turn off your your
console for welcome back the people
immediately around so cool use that
that's the best boss fight in any game
but if they're waiting for the bell to
ring and then they see you shoot the
bell when they just go do
dude I saw you i'm not i'm not gonna
leave just cuz usually i'm waiting for
the bell to ring i'm good i'm still
going to attack you are they just that
dumb i don't know i guess so well
they're they're not like in their right
minds are they are any of us no i guess
not if i would i would not be surprised
if you came like lurching at me with a
butcher knife one day I would be I would
say okay that makes sense office is a
scary place one less game want to throw
in there because not to like diminish it
whatsoever but just because it's in
September it's right like during out the
kind of the September law which is not
something you always say I guess
October's pretty crazy talk about
September that often no I've never
mentioned September in a sentence no
that's my birthday month take a guess
quick sixteenth no first day of fall
twenty second too slow precor is coming
out September 15th I believe yeah you
know like you know Funes attached to it
and tomorrow who saying wrote a good
story about it saying this might be like
the real Mega Man's successor you're
looking for after a game that didn't do
so well lately the Pete reviewed I dunno
but no not a lot of people liked it so
recore like a 3d metroid prime megaman
is that accurate to say no no metroid
prime is a first-person game I get that
but I will say some nutrients the
environments look pretty similar I
actually don't know a whole lot about
recore I was surprised to see the game
was sort of more of a budget title in a
way I could selling for 40 bucks and it
seems to have an aesthetic that is maybe
befitting last gen rather than this gen
so I'm but in some ways I'm that makes
me wonder if they're able to put more
time until a weird mechanics and weird
encounters if they're not wasting a lot
of budget on visuals say so okay i'm
curious about curious about it same here
we'll see how that goes that'll be
September before october hits as the
vertibird usually happened September
precedes October comes after august
what's the poem and I got halfway three
days half October but September is
sometimes before october if you're
counting a leap year there you have it
Justin hey wold everyone alright so that
is kind of our wrap-up of the games left
this summer things you can get into if
you haven't already caught up on the
enormous spring catalog that kind of
bombarded us a lot of good games there
I don't know let us know you think in
the comments what your looking forward
to playing any recommendations you have
for us sipho because he'll probably be
too busy playing other games I'm just
not into those games so whatever you're
gonna recommend know that Pete's gonna
pet Pete's gonna be a pizza reviews
editor he knows what's hot you don't
have to tell him yeah that's hot look I
don't have time for this right yeah just
get up and walk away